[Müzik]
Ben Murat Arıncı biraz kendinden
bahsedeyim Türk Turizm'in 98 yılında
Öger ailesi ile başlayan ve aslen kendi
kökeninin otomotiv sektörü olan Mercedes
Benz kolomonlar altyapısıyla yıllarca
bir serüvenin içerisinde bir Akademi
Okulu ile beraber başlayan Turizm
konaklama sektöründeki yeterlilikleri
bir ölçmeye başladık Bununla ilgili de
ne yapmamız gerek derken satın almak
dünyasındaki boşluğu gördük ve izledik
bir filtre yaptık buradaki doğrular
yanlışlar maliyetlerle postlarla ilgili
iyice bir ilke yaratmayı düşündük ve bir
STK kurduk bu Turizm konaklama
sektörünün Türkiye'de de satın alma
müdürleri eğitim derneğinin ve
Türkiye'de
2010 yılında kurulan bu dernekte
başlayan Hikayemiz akademis Akademi
dünyasına da bir el attık ve kalktık
Nikola akademiyi kurduk
altının sonunda gerçekleşen bu
nikakademi A şeyiyle beraber de çok
bölgeleri gezmeye başladık
tesisleşmeleri ve bütün
departmanlardaki Konsept
farklılıklarıyla beraber
sanayileşen bu konudaki bütün
konseptlerim ve yöneticilerin kendi
kendine ilgi alanlarında neler
yarattıklarını izledik ve biz bize ne
düşer derken de Bölgemizdeki yöresel
Turizm konaklamanın en değerli olan
bölümünü müşteri memnuniyet olan
gastronomi bölümündeki bölgesel ve
küresel ürünler üzerinde ithal ürünler
üzerinde satın almalara başladık Ve
tamamen dinamasyon bakımlı otelin
tamamen bütün dünyasındaki satın alma
hareketliliklerine cevap vermeye
başladık Ama yetmedi bütün bölgeleri
gezmeye başlayınca da bu Seyit abi bizi
çok farklı farklı yerlere farklı farklı
alanlara taşıdı
insanlarla tanıştıkça bütün bölgelerdeki
kendine has kendine öz özelliklerini
fark ettik ve kabullendik çok değerli
şeyler çıkarttık her bölge Bodrum
fethiyesi Marmaris'te efendime
söyleyeyim Ayvalık bölgesi Marmara
Bölgesi Karadeniz her bölgenin Emre Han
anlattığı gibi kültürel değerlerine iyi
hitap eden ve buradaki müşteri
memnuniyetinin Konsept farklılıklarıyla
beraber bir tatlı yarışları gördük sonra
bununla ilgili de genel anlamda farklı
stk'larla işbirliği ile beraber tamamen
Turizm konaklama sektörünün
departman üst düzey yöneticileri ve
bunlarla beraber harmanladığımız eğitim
alanları üniversitelerle Çalışmaya
başlayınca iş daha farklı bir yere geldi
Bunu da tamamen kadrolarımız ve
akademisyen katkılarıyla bölgesel ve tüm
bölgelerdeki beyi belirlediğimiz
üniversitelerin üzerinden de çok güzel
projeler ve planlamalar yaptık bu sefer
ne yaptık bir pandemi geldi Herkes bir
kozasına böyle saklandığı ne yaptık
pandemi de çok önemli değerli bir un yay
eğitimle tanıştık İnsanlar kendi özünü
kendi ile ilgili efendime söyleyeyim
yeterliliklerini tartmaya başladılar bir
sistem akmaya başladı aktıkça da bu
sistem pandemi boyunca insanlar dedi ki
ya bir dakika ya bizim kendi eksiğimizi
karakter ve yaşam akışımızdaki
farklılıkları fazlalıkları eksikleri
gördük biz bu sefer baktık ki tedx işte
Büyük şehirlerde üniversite Metropol
Mega şehirlerde bu Tetik sistemi ve
bunları izlemek için özel biletten aldık
gittik insanlar ne anlatıyor duygularını
anlatıyor
hassasiyetlerini anlatıyor
kütüphanelerinde kapatmış olduğu çok
güzel anılarını dışarıya veremeyen
insanlar birazcık onunla uğraşmaya
başlamış ve işin içine yazarlar Evet
bugün de çok güzel keyifli insanlar
keyifli psikolog hocalarımız var önemli
bölgesel ve coğrafi şeylerde çok önemli
hikayeler dinleyeceğiz bu değerlerle
beraber de farklı farklı güzel İnsanları
Tanıma şansını Tetik sayesinde bulduk ve
Dedik ki bir dakika ya Turizm konaklama
sektöründe bir tetiks neden yapılması
Emrah da benim çok değerli arkadaşım
zaten eğitim alanlarında Sürekli bir
araya geliyor ne yaparız lisans onun
dedik ki hemen bunu hayata geçirelim 3
aydan belli gerçekten çok kıymetli bir
emekle beraber sevdiklerin karşısına
çıkmayı düşündük ve buradaki
konuşmacıları seçerken de bölgesel ve
farklı farklı alanlarda farklı farklı
biyolojik düşünceleriyle beraber İnsan
fıtratlarını bir harmanladık çok güzel
bir bugün muhteşem insanların
düetleriyle beraber akşamleyin herkes
evinde ve sohbetlerinde Yarınlarda başka
yerlerde bizlere konuşacaklarına iddia
ediyorum güzel bir akşamı bitireceğiz
bugün Evet burada önemli olan
şu bunu unutmamamız lazım
insanlar güzel özel kütüphanelerindeki o
gizemli dünyaları artık konuşması lazım
Türkiye'de İnanın ben bunu çok önemli
bir anket haline getirdim insanlar
konuşamıyor insanlar derdini anlatamıyor
insanlar doğru tartışamıyor insanlar
kendisini çok güzel ifade edemiyor
insanlar doğru haklılığını bile ifade
edemediğinden dolayı mağlup oluyor
insanlar konuşacak insanlar kendisini bu
Ruhi muhabbetin içerisinde her yaşamın
akışında ifade özgürlüğünü iyi
kullanacaklar onunla ilgili çok önemli
çalışmalar başladı Türkiye'de insanlar
gelişmeye başladı bu hareketlilik beni
mutlu ediyor Ben 5 yıl öncesine kadar
çok karamsardım bu tür tartışmalarda çok
acı ya umutsuzum diye Şey yapıyordum ama
üniversitelerimizdeki belli çok güzel
tabelası yüksek üniversitelerimiz bu işi
çok güzel yapıyor ve Türkiye'de
Gerçekten muhteşem algı ve yükleme ve
mevzuattaki efendime söyleyeyim
insanlara kimlik yeterliliğinin yükleme
sistemini iyi yapmaya başladılar Bugün
ben mesela Hacettepe Üniversitesi'nin
çok benim ODTÜ saatten konuşacak kadar
çok değerli bir mesela Bununla ilgili
efendime söyleyeyim güzel
üniversitelerinde İstanbul
Üniversitesi'ne bayılıyorum hayranım ve
çok davetlerine gidip Onların da belli
Konsept şeylerinde de satış Eee satın
alma ve tedarik zinciri eğitimlerine
girdiğim için çok güzel şeyler şahit
oluyoruz Evet bugün gerçekten değerli
insanlarla değerli arkadaşlarımızla
değerli Turizm konaklama sektöründeki
siz değerli konuklarımıza muhteşem bir
günü ilk Allah ve bir arada yapacağız ve
yaşayacağız Evet burada Öncelikle
yönetim kurulu başkanımız Aydın Bey
grubun Enes ünlüleri çok teşekkür
ediyoruz bütün yönetim kurulu
arkadaşlarımızla beraber onlara Biz
yönetim kurulu arkadaşlar onların
yönetim kurullarına çok teşekkür
ediyoruz ev sahipliği yaptılar bize bu
imkanı tanıdığı için Evet burada
özellikle Erdoğan Turan Bey çok emek
verdi Sağ olsun Bu grubun CEO'su
teşekkür ediyoruz ve genel müdürü Can
Özer ve hem Hayırlı olsun diyoruz o
arkadaşımız da ayrı teşekkür ediyoruz Bu
ekip arkadaşlarımızın alt kadrolarında
bütün emeği geçen bütün dostlarımıza
ayrı teşekkür ediyoruz burada
üstünden geçemeyeceğim Emrah Kozan
kardeşim ve bizim Türkiye Turizm
platformunun bu platformunda tanıtmak
istiyorum öne özellikle Türk turizmi ve
farklı alanlardaki meslek alanların
içerisinde yüz düzey yöneticilerin ve
bölgesel çalışmalardaki bu tür sempozyum
panel ve birlik beraberliği Kuran bir
birliktir bu birliğin bir başkanı yoktur
ama muhteşem insanların içinde
olduğunuzu dönem dönem bizlerin Türkiye
Turizm platformunda akış ve ee
profesyonel Efendim Yol haritalarını
sizlere de anlatacağız Bundan dolayı
Emrah Bey'e çok teşekkür ediyoruz Niko
Akademi Ayriyetten eğitim alanında ve
farklı farklı sponsorlarımızın hepsini
bizlere buraya destek oldular bu
oluşumun içerisinde olan Bütün
arkadaşlarımızın hepsini ayrı ayrı çok
çok teşekkür ediyorum ve güzel bir
tetiksin başlaması için sizlere teşekkür
ediyorum İyi ki varsınız saygılarım
sunuyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]